it is my sworn duty and probably illegal
to bring you the latest of these
conversations we have the latest
snippets of some of their conversations
from the last day or so here they are
hello hey bear what size should I put
your dad for a baby I'm a large fuzz for
what it's a thank-you gift for being so
nice to me during this transition okay
fine a large them great so we ride to
deliver together on Inauguration okay
that's the plan yeah what are we gonna
talk about I don't know
yeah me neither it's gonna be awkward
doesn't have to be believe me it's gonna
be awkward what because I'm definitely
hitting on the show with translators of
course there's an entire division of the
State Department dedicated to that good
I'm going to need that you mean four
trips abroad no conversations with
Melania hello you're enjoying your last
few days of the White House
I am Abby you're not gonna you know do
something to the mattress are you what
are you talking about you know what I'm
talking about fake news you mean am I
gonna hire hookers to pee on the
mattress that you're about to leave up
exactly
no I'm not thank you I don't have to Joe
Biden volunteer to do it for free Oh two
o'clock in the morning I know I can't
sleep what I can't sleep that's when the
bathtub Clark once season seven of
Celebrity Apprentice
I fired Gilbert Godfrey instead of
Jurado even though the store window
display Gilbert did pretty wood first
place I need a total prize so I think
there's more important stuff you should
have doubts about you're right like I
can't stop wondering if Milania used to
be a mess her voice
I gotta go
[Applause]
you